[Música]
stalingrado Unión soviética 31 de enero
de 1943 friedrich paulus comandante del
sexto ejército alemán se rinde tras
meses de guerra en un cruento invierno
meses antes en medio de la operación
barbarroja adolf Hitler ordena dividir
las tropas que buscaban tomar el caucaso
al sur de Rusia para conquistar la
estratégica ciudades stalingrado
[Música]
con la toma de la ciudad de stalin la
Alemania nazi buscaba un golpe simbólico
y moral en medio de una ciudad destruida
por los bombardeos de la luz bafen la
fuerza aérea alemana el campo de guerra
se vuelve un territorio óptimo para los
francotiradores y la lucha caza a casa a
finales de 1942 los nazis controlan casi
la totalidad de la ciudad y el destino
de la urbe parece definido sin embargo
en secreto la unión soviética estaba
acumulando cerca de un millón de
combatientes Al Otro Lado Del Río volga
en lo que se denominó operación Urano
tras la ofensiva soviética a principios
de 1943 más de 300.000 soldados alemanes
habían quedado atrapados gracias al
movimiento de pinza del ejército rojo a
finales de enero el esfuerzo alemán por
abastecer las tropas rodeadas resulta
infructuoso los soviéticos capturan
90.000 soldados nazis
finalmente el 2 de febrero de 1943 los
combates cesan y una de las batallas más
importantes de la Segunda Guerra Mundial
llega su fin dejando más de 2 millones
300.000 personas muertas
800.000 combatientes del bando alemán y
cerca de un millón y medio en tres
soldados y civiles soviéticos
[Música]